[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette foire
aux questions sur un tract aux sciences
ou j'accueille aujourd'hui le docteur
thierry smith thierry bonjour bonjour
donc thierry et paléontologue à
l'institut royal des sciences naturelles
de belgique et spécialiste des
mammifères paléocène et c'est pour ça
qu'on invite aujourd'hui afin de nous
parler de ce tout nouvel article qui est
sorti il ya une semaine de cela à peu
près donc
un article qui nous raconte finalement
comment les mammifères
se sont diversifiées après l'extinction
crétacé paléogène et qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit et qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup
alerté les médias y compris les médias
francophones et du coup bien jeu
c'est pour ça que nous invitons
aujourd'hui thierry smith c'est pour
justement avoir un commentaire éclairé
sur ce que cet article nous apporte de
nouveaux est sûre et peut-être nous
apporter aussi un petit regard critique
sur sur son contenu
donc déjà peut-être pour commencer est
ce que est ce que est ce que tu pourrais
nous décrira rapidement le contenu de
cet article
oui bien sûr julien donc cet article est
très intéressant parce qu'en fait c'est
pas un article classique nos
paléontologie c c'est vraiment une étude
multidisciplinaire il ya seize auteurs à
l'article c'est un article un peu
inhabituel je dirai pas ce que pour la
revue science d'habitude les articles
sont pas présentés comme ça et ici on a
vraiment un
c'est plutôt un calcul c'est un espèce
d'énorme calcul mathématique sur le
premier million d'années qui suit la
limite crétacé paléogène et dans l'étude
multidisciplinaire on a de la
stratigraphie à haute résolution
donc les collègues américains ont
vraiment étudié le bassin de denver au
colorado dans avec une approche vraiment
à haute résolution graphique très
précises ils ont fait ça ils ont ajouté
à ça du paléomagnétisme de la paléo
palynologie donc l'étude des pollens et
sport met vraiment en détail alors
l'étude des feuilles
il retrouve toute une série de feuilles
qui sont magnifiques et par le calcul
des températures
les températures maximales de l'époque
qui est basée sur la bordure des
feuilles sur les stomates sur les
nervures et c'est donc sur la structure
des feuilles donc il faut pour ça
connaître la diversité des feuilles et
enfin sur les vertébrés où ils ont
étudié trois groupes les mammifères les
crocodiles et les tortues donc il nous
faut une grosse coupe avec tout ça et il
essaye de reconstituer le premier
million d'années qui suit la limite cap
est d'accord et quand tu parles de quand
tu parles de stratigraphie à haute
résolution de quel genre de résolution
parle en quoi c'est différent de la
résolution normal j'ai envie de dire oui
mais en fait c'est parce que en europe
on a une stratigraphie qui est
généralement un grand patchwork entre
dumas un beau coup je suis belge donc en
belgique on a une stratigraphie qu ait
connue depuis au moins le 19e siècle une
série d' étage de l'échelle géologique
des temps qui établit en belgique et on
a une stratigraphie qu est très marines
et classique c'est là dessus qu'on base
la stratigraphie et on a quelques
épisodes continentaux finalement et on
essaye de reconstituer l'ensemble
maintenant il ya des régions du monde
que ce soit en asie
que ce soit en amérique du nord et ou en
inde un peu aussi en amérique du sud où
on a des grands bassins sédimentaires
continentaux comme c'est le cas ici dans
cette étude
et d'ailleurs ils comparent quatre
bassins bon ils viennent montrer que le
bassin qui ont étudié et évidemment le
meilleur et le plus complexe est un peu
le but de l'article
mais effectivement ces grands bassins
sédimentaires qui a par exemple au
wyoming le montana au nouveau mexique ou
au calme au colorado dans leur cas sont
des bassins extraordinaire avec des
centaines voire des milliers de mètres
d'épaisseur entièrement continental et
où on a vraiment une succession qui sont
comme les pages d'un livre avec des
faunes et des flores l'une ou l'autre ou
parfois les deux c'est rarement les deux
ensemble mais qui
sans chasse dans cette stratégie graphie
et on a vraiment on peut suivre parfois
moi j'ai travaillé au wyoming donc je
connais mieux évidemment cette région là
mais où l'on peut suivre les lignes et
par exemple des mammifères à travers le
temps pratiquement un homme même endroit
dans la section faut reconnaître qu'il a
pas beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde où
on peut faire de la palynologie de la
palynologie pardon de la paléontologie
pas lino et vertébrés dents avec une
résolution pareil quoi ouais parce que
je vois dans l'article il parle quand
même de 27 kilomètres carrés de doubt
crop donc 25 km² d'affleurements qui sur
sur une section de 250 m c'est 250
mètres d'épaisseur oui dix jours 250
mètres parce qu'ils se sont limités à au
premier million d'années qui suit la
limite cap et quand nous a travaillé au
wyoming
je me rappelle qu'on avait 700 m pour le
paléo scène et on avait 1200 mètres rien
pour les océanes inférieur donc tu vois
les épaisseurs c'est colossal et s'est
étendu sur des kilomètres et des
kilomètres carrés donc c'est vraiment
bon c'est différent de la petite
belgique où nous on a des couples qui
font trois mètres de haut et donc du
coup c'est ce serait ces épaisseurs
sédimentaires qu'apporterait de nouveau
cet article c'est qu'est-ce qui a
finalement qu'est-ce que cet article
apporte de nouveau parce que ce qu'on
voit beaucoup sur internet c'est
finalement on nous dit finalement on a
enfin une image de comment les
mammifères ont pris le contrôle de la
terre après l'extinction des dinosaures
mais enfin c'est quelque chose qu'on
savait déjà ça donc qu'est-ce que cet
article finalement apporte de nouveau
est ce que c'est juste ce point de vue
sédimentaires et si et si c'est surtout
le point de vue sédimentaires dans ce
cas qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il y a de
plus qu'avant en fait voilà oui mais là
j'imagine qu'il ya aussi l'aspect
médiatique parce qu'il faut reconnaître
qu'ils ont une foi de vertébrés qui est
vraiment exceptionnel pour ce premier
million d'années dont qui suit
l'extinction des dinosaures ça c'est
remarquable
et à mon avis d'ailleurs dans le futur
ils devront étudier ça plus en détail
taxons par taxons
jusqu'ici ce qu'ils disent dans
l'article c'est que cette action était
déjà connu c'est vrai que il était déjà
connu à l'état plus fragmentaire il si
l'on descend des craintes complet coin
et qui sont dans certains sont gardés en
trois dimensions vraiment dans un état
exceptionnel quoi y'a pas d'autre mot
qu'exceptionnel et là aussi il faudrait
voir la variabilité faudrait voir bon
quand même c'est un découpage parfois de
quelques millions d'années où on a les
mêmes espèces qui suivent la limite qui
appelle faudrait voir si c'est vraiment
les neuf espèces il faudrait voir la
variabilité dans le détail etc
j'imagine qu'ils vont faire ça dans le
futur on a effectivement l'impression
qu'on a
d'après l'article qu'on a compris ce qui
se passe avec l'appareil
l'apparition la succession le
développement des mammifères
après c'est timide cap et moi dans le
paléontologue c'est pas tellement ça que
je vois à travers l'article mais
j'imagine que pour les médias c'était un
petit peu compliqué et techniques
d'expliquer cet article ce que moi je
vois surtout c'est le timing qui suit la
ligne l'extinction des dinosaures
c'est à dire que ce qu'ils expliquent
bien sur base de leur étude
multidisciplinaire je le répète c'est
que dans les soixante à cent mille ans
qui suivent la disparition des
dinosaures il reste plus grand chose
puisque évidemment on a une extinction
des dinosaures mais on sait bien qu'on a
une grosse diminution des espèces dans
différents groupes y compris les
mammifères faut savoir que des livres et
des mammifères qui passe la limite
capter il y en a extrêmement peu et donc
ici ce qu'il montre c'est que cent mille
ans environ cent mille ans après la
limite k p il ya une espèce de ce qu'ils
appellent un recovery a donc une
reconquête des niches écologiques on
retrouve une certaine diversité
seulement cent mille ans après la limite
capé et à ce moment là la diversité des
mammifères et environs doublé après cent
mille ans ce qu'il constate c'est que si
on se situe un peu près 300 mille ans
après cette limite capés puisque jeu
je répète on peut suivre dans ses
bassins une succession qui est
magnifiquement complète qui sont comme
les pages d'un livre donc on peut
vraiment se situer précisément où on est
environ trois cent mille ans après la
limite cap et on constate que la masse
corporelle des mammifères qui se trouve
là a triplé
donc on a vraiment un développement en
taille en masse des mammifères on
constate que cette masse corporelle qui
a triplé coïncident plus ou moins
parfaitement avec une augmentation de la
diversité spécifique de la méga flower
et enfin environ 700 mille ans après la
limite cap et on constate qu'on à
l'apparition de nouveaux mammifères de
nouvelles espèces de grande taille
alors quand on dit grande taille c'est
pas des éléphants ou des baleines c'est
certain c'est des animaux qui vont
jusqu'à 25 kg il faut savoir pour des
mammifères de cette époque-là 25 kg
c'est énorme
1 parce qu'on vient d'animaux qui ont la
taille d'une souris d'une musaraigne
auriverde 25 kg c'est beaucoup et ça se
passe sur 700 bilan suivant le
l'extinction des dinosaures du rock
c'est quand même à l'échelle géologique
c'est rapide et alors pour terminer mon
explication ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'ils constatent que ces trois
événements que je viens de citer sont
mille trois cent mille sept cent mille
correspondent apparemment à des
réchauffements climatiques
alors c'est pas de réchauffement
climatique comme on connaît pour la
limite pas lieu c'est newton qui est un
réchauffement climatique
bestiale qui d'ailleurs est comparée au
réchauffement actuel anthropogénique en
tout cas les scientifiques de plus en
plus pour ça tous pour ça pour étudier
cette limite paléocène eocène parce que
c'est une bonne comparaison même si
évidemment l'homme était pas là il ya 56
millions d'années c'est pas des
réchauffements de ce type là mais c'est
quand même un réchauffement de l'ordre
de d'environ cinq degrés en moyenne pour
le premier épisode qui se passe à 13
cents mille ans et les épisodes à 300
milliards sept cent mille après la
limite cap et sont des réchauffements de
l'ordre de
3° donc ça c'est quand même intéressant
est alors en fait il ya encore un autre
notre événement que je dois je dois
citer c'est l'événement vers 700 mille
ans quand on donc on à l'apparition de
nouvelles espèces y compris des
mammifères de grande taille et bien ça
coïncide avec l'apparition des
légumineuses les légumineuses
ce sont des plantes extrêmement
importante dans l'évolution
parce que on les connaissait les comment
les enregistrements fossiles les plus
anciens notamment en amérique du sud est
ou était aux alentours de 58 60 millions
d'années
ici ils ont l'apparition 700 mille ans
après la limite cap et des légumineuses
donc on est quand même à 65 millions
d'années donc ils ont en même temps le
plus ancien enregistrement de
légumineuses alors les légumineuses
c'est la famille des fabacées et les
fabas et c'est tout ce qui donne les
haricots le soja les lentilles donc on a
tout de suite compris que pour des
mammifères pouvoir manger des
légumineuses c'est un apport nutritif
énorme
donc j'imagine que ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui vont suivre plus tard
avec d'autres études parce que une
relation entre la flore et la faune avec
des apparitions de plantes qui sont
capitales dans l'évolution de certains
vertébrés et de mettre tout ça ensemble
avec des réchauffements climatiques tout
ça après l'extinction des dinosaures
là faut reconnaître chapeau avec une
faune exceptionnelle c'est surtout
l'accumulation toutes les données et
cette faune qui est qui qui je suis tout
à fait d'accord
valais la publication dans science
maintenant bon effectivement l'article
est un petit peu technique un petit peu
compliqué et je peux imaginer que les
médias ont réduit sa à une faune
exceptionnelle donc donc
si on si on résume tout ça donc l'apport
de cet article c'est tout d'abord une
section continue qui commence donc une
section géologique continue qui commence
au crétacé qui se continue au début du
paléocène et donc qui documentent ces
variations des faunes de mammifères donc
on a des mammifères qui faisait huit
kilos maximum avant la limite crétacé
tertiaire
il est en gros après ça donc il ya tous
ces c'est palier de diversification que
tu nous a décrit avec à cent mille ans
une diversité qui est doublé et en gros
un million d'années on a des mammifères
de 50 kg qui sont déjà donc en un
million d'années
cette nouvelle section finalement elle
documente l'art l'art diversification
des mammifères après 50 millions
d'années il n'y a pas d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas que des mammifères
si si je ne m'abuse il ya aussi des
crocos des tortues voilà mais ça il faut
aussi dire que le premier auteur donc
tyler leisen je sais pas si on dit lise
online je suppose la zone est en fait un
spécialiste de tortue donc il ya les
tortues et qui ont été étudiées aussi
mais évidemment les tortues et les
crocodiles ne montre pas eu une telle
diversification d'ailleurs on en parle
très peu dans l'article de ces groupes
là aussi parce que bon pour étudier la
masse corporelle c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus facile de le faire sur les
mammifères où on sait que les comment la
conquête des niches écologiques par des
mammifères vu leur métabolisme assez
élevé le lait croissance rapide etc
il vaut mieux étudier ces groupes là
pour voir la reconquête des niches
écologiques juste après l'extinction
oui oui tyler c'est un éminent
spécialiste des reptiles à la base c'est
un peu ça à la base il est connu pour
avoir trouvé une momie d'adp rose or je
crois qui est la momie de dakota si je
ne m'abuse
et effectivement il a fait énormément
d'articles sur l'origine des des tortues
à partir de justement de noto russe qui
vient d'afrique du sud
donc oui ce c'est un peu sa première
incursion dans le monde des mammifères
quoi mais ces programmes et emails dont
il est encadré de paléo mano gist les
minots comme dave creuser stephen
schuster donc là j'en vois deux oui
c'est ça je vois william klein william
klein lui c'est pas un palier obama
logist c'est quelqu'un qui fait du
paléomagnétisme notamment donc cueilli
en fait il s'est bien entouré d'une
série de spécialistes pour étudier sa
section mais c'est vrai que la section
qu'il a été magnifique parce que tous
ces bassins sédimentaires continentaux
très complet quand même sont retrouvés
le long des montagnes rocheuses
depuis le canada jusqu'au nouveau
mexique et ses bassins bon même si c'est
ton très complet au niveau des défauts
une par exemple certains peuvent être
très complet pour la faune et la flore
est pas extraordinaire
d'autres ont une flore et une faune
superbe mais la succession
stratigraphique à quelques astuces
et ici bon il a une très bonne section
et en plus il ay la quasi tous deux dans
quoi donc il a pu étudier son premier
million d'années dans le détail il ya
aussi la enfin la quantité de proxy
qu'ils ont pu utiliser pour les dates
parce que ça c'est quelque chose
fac justement puisqu'on parlait de la
stratigraphie à haute résolution 7
stratigraphie à haute résolution elle
est extrêmement dépendante des datations
est là pour le coup il a vraiment il a
vraiment pu appliquer une quantité de
techniques différentes pour s'assurer
que les datations été bonne qui est tout
à fait de jolis ils ont un niveau de
cendres volcaniques qui est qui et qui
comment quedate honda façon absolue donc
bon il oui ils ont j'allais dire ils ont
de la chance mais c'est jeudi recèle la
région est extraordinaire ça c'est clair
géologiquement c'est superbe je sais
qu'on a des auditeurs qui sont souvent
sceptiques quant il s'agit de datation
mais là il ya quand même alors
l'utilisation ils ont dit ils disent
dans l'article donc qui l'ont utilisé
déjà ils ont utilisé les intervalles les
à comment ça s'appelle les normes
américaines landes mammal edge donc
lewis à la biostratigraphie l'ont
utilisé la biostratigraphie mammalienne
la palynologie donc il ya aussi une
biostratigraphie palin aux logiques qui
coïncide avec 3 magnéto kron ça veut
dire qu'ils ont utilisé les inversions
de chants et les inverse innti champs
magnétiques pour dater l'heure roche ils
ont utilisé donc une datations
radiométriques sur ce niveau 2 de
cendres volcaniques
enfin bref ils ont ils ont vraiment
énormément de techniques différentes et
indépendantes pour pour dater se voit là
pour dater cette session c'est pour ça
que cela explique le fait que ses
auteurs oui c'est vrai que du coup il
faut du monde
il faut une grande quantité de
spécialistes et je vais rebondir sur
déjà déjà sur la préservation
tu as parlé du coût de la préservation
exceptionnelles comment comment ça se
compare avec ce qu'on trouve ailleurs
au même âge cette préservation c'est à
dire battre on trouvait des crânes
complet on est d'accord que c'est
finalement c'est assez commun dans le
crétacé je veux dire des crânes de
dinosaures complet ils en ont quand même
beaucoup dans en amérique du nord au
crétacé alors quel est ce que est ce que
c'était pas pareil pour les mammifères
en gros au paléo scène
non c'est pas du tout pareil parce qu'en
fait c'est peut-être un peu paradoxal
mais on a beaucoup plus de crâne anciens
que de crâne plus récents sauf si
évidemment se trouve dans le nez aux
jeunes aux dents quaternaire mais dans
le palais aux gènes on n'a pas tant de
crainte que ça sauf certains sites bien
bien connu et le psn est malheureusement
toute une période qui est extrêmement
mal connue même si elle est connue
depuis longtemps la faune de mammifères
en particulier est mal connu par exemple
en europe
on sait très très peu parce qu'il ya
plus quelques sites qui sont connus il
ya le site de cernier béru dans le passé
dans bassin de paris où on a dans le
gisement des rues effectivement des
craintes complet dont un certain nombre
de craintes qui sont restés en trois
dimensions et là on connaît relativement
bien cette faune mais elle date du
palais 5 supérieur donc on sait qu'on
est loin de 20 pas loin mais déjà 7 8
millions d'années de la limite cap et
donc pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas l'idéal
on est déjà avec des mammifères d'assez
grande taille donc on n'a pas tous les
événements après la limite cap et en
asie on a on a quelques gisements déjà
pas mal
de la commande du paléocène mais souvent
là des problèmes datation en asie la
succession n'est pas aussi complète que
les grands bassins sédimentaires ouest
américain et la biostratigraphie n'est
pas toujours au point
donc c'est pas facile de dater les sites
maintenant il faut reconnaître que les
américains dans l'ouest américain
travaille là depuis longtemps
ils savent qu'ils ont des bassins très
complet et donc aller travailler
spécifiquement sur le premier million
d'années qui suit la limite capé et est
tombé sur une finalement sur ces sites
qui ont donné ces faux nez c'est que
c'est exceptionnel
là c'est vraiment ils ont faim ils ont
énormément de chance donc je pense que
dans le futur il faut qu'une série de
gens se penche là-dessus pour pour
étudier les faunes aussi dans le détail
maintenant parce qu'on peut peut-être
comprendre d'autres choses
oui parce que là pour l'instant ils
n'ont pas des cris d enfin ils ont
identifié ce qu'ils on trouve les
espèces qu'ils ont trouvée mais au final
ils ont ya probablement des nouvelles
espèces qui vont se trouver dans l'eau
est de même des choses qu'on savait
qu'on ne savait pas à propos des espèces
déjà connus je pense que s'il n'en parle
pas dans l'article c'est normal
l'article est focalisée sur ces
événements chronologique qui suivent
l'extinction des dinosaures et s'est
focalisé là dessus
en fait j'ai envie de dire c'est un
article qui donne un peu l'eau à la
bouche puisque on voudrait on voudrait
maintenant savoir quelle va être la
suite quoi parce que c'est oui dans les
mammifères bon moi je vois ici sous les
yeux des photos de crâne il ya des
animaux qu'on connaissait que par des
fragments et là on a des craintes
complet donc ouais c'est assez
exceptionnel
on se demande quand est-ce qu'il ya tous
les matériels post crânien associé à ça
est ce que parce que pour avoir autant
de crâne complet il doit y avoir le
reste est donc ce qu'ils peuvent pas
tenter des reconstitutions ces
mammifères
c'est quand même une série de mammifères
du début du palio celle où actuellement
on sait absolument pas quoi il
ressemblait quoi il ya des lits et des
ordres entier où on qu'on connaît par
quelques dents et on ne sait absolument
pas à quoi ressemble et ses animaux et
qui n'ont aucun représentant moderne au
paléo je dors aucun représentant moderne
exactement donc campus et julien notre
groupe travaille sur seille de
travailler sur l'origine des mammifères
modernes les mammifères modernes c'est à
dire les mammifères qui existe
aujourd'hui
mais leur premier représentant
apparaissent il ya 56 millions d'années
c'est à dire 10 mise 10 10 millions
d'années après cette extinction des
dinosaures donc 10 millions d'années
après la limite k p et donc c'est vrai
que c'est 10 millions donc on comprend
plus ou moins ce qui se passe les
cinquante six derniers millions d'années
donc dès qu'on a les premiers mammifères
modernes de la donc les primes acquises
chauves souris les cétacés les rongeurs
les carnivores vrai donc apparaissent il
ya 56 millions d'années dans
l'enregistrement en fossiles ça veut pas
dire qu'ils optent ils apparaissent en
tombant de la planète parce c'est pas ça
parfois on pense ça parce que comme on
trouve pas leurs ancêtres à la fin on en
a marre et on deale bombay partons du
principe qu'ils viennent de la planète
mars ça va simplifier nos recherches
parce que là on devient fou ça fait un
siècle et demi qu'on travaille là dessus
et qu'on trouve pas les les ancêtres et
donc c'est pour ça que les
paléontologues 2
de mon équipe où des gens qui
travaillent sur la même époque sur la
limite pas lieu saint hyacinthe
ce soit aussi beaucoup intéressé au
palais au sein dans dix ans on doit
trouver les ancêtres de ces mammifères
modernes
jusqu'ici on a tout le temps des taxons
qu'on dit archaïque
parce qu'il s'éteigne dont courant de
l'est au sein probablement par
compétition avec les mammifères modernes
qui devait être plus efficace et donc on
cherche des ancêtres dans ces mammifères
du palio scène mais on les trouve pas
vraiment ici quoi c'est quoi cette
action c'est qu'elles sont ces groupes
archaïque
ces groupes par quelques belles d'abord
il y en a un premier qui est un grand
classique qu'on appelle les condyles
artres alors les condyles artres c'est
un groupe poubelle c'est à dire que
c'est grosso modo tout un tas
d'herbivores nom moderne donc des
animaux qui avaient la niche écologique
des premiers périssent au dactyle des
premiers petits chevaux ou des premiers
a reçus au tactile mais qui ne sont ni
périssent aux actes il n'y a rien eu
d'acte il donc on les a mis dans les
conduits à retrouver dans des animaux
qui ont des dents qu'on va appeler bruno
dhont donc des deux rangs à bosse qui
qui qui j'ai pas dire qui broutaient
mais qui mangeaient des végétaux est qui
qui ont disparu on a un autre groupe qui
est aussi qu'est quand même assez connu
ce sont les plaisirs d'api fort parce
qu'il ya le genre plaisir d'api ce qui
était considéré longtemps comme un
primate
pour ma part ce grand groupe ne sont pas
ce ne sont pas des primates se font des
mammifères arboricole donc il y avait
une niche écologique similaire aux
primates
mais quand on voit un squelette complet
de plaisir d'appui forme mais on se rend
compte que il n'avait pas la mains
préhensiles ils n'ont pas le pouce
opposable aux autres doigts
il avait des griffes pas des ongles i
grow up grimper comme des écureuils pas
comme des primates
surtout ils n'ont pas la barre post
orbitaire qui est fermée donc avec les
yeux qui sont ramenés de face et la
vision stéréoscopique
mais ils ont des yeux latéraux comme un
lapin ils ont déjà toute une série de
spécialisation avec des longues incisif
comme des rongeurs et non pas des peu
incisif comme on les premiers primates
ils ont déjà des réductions voire des
disparitions de prémolaires que n'ont
pas les premiers primates
enfin pour moi tout ce groupe des
plaisirs d'api forme ne donne pas les
primates
je vais bien qu'il soit mon frère assez
lointain mais en tout cas pour moi il ne
donne pas les primates
mais bon c'est un groupe important qui a
perduré tout une partie de ce palier aux
ânes et il va aussi s'éteindre dans le
courant de l'est au sein probablement
par compétition avec les primates on a
d'autres groupes les petites idées les
cils modestie des ce sont des groupes
qu'on voit souvent associée à des
insectivores mais c'est pas des
insectivores comme les insectivores
modernes se sont insectivores dit
archaïque mais toute cette faune de ces
animaux archaïque sont là dans le palio
sun disparaissent la plupart
disparaissent dans le courant de
l'automne probablement par compétition
mais il faut bien qu'on trouve les
ancêtres de ces mammifères modernes
donc on cherche d'abord dans le palu est
saine et bien encore d'autres choses les
pentes au dont tu les dinos et rate
les voilà donc il ya vraiment tout
en fait c'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir que donc on sait cet
article pour en revenir à cet article il
est résumé par les médias comme la
grande radiation des mammifères donc
comment ce commet une nouvelle
découverte à documenter la grande
radiation des mammifères après
l'extinction des dinosaures
mais cette radiation de mammifères en
fait elle a rien à voir avec les
mammifères modernes et on sait ça n'a
rien à voir avec les mammifères modernes
mais bon les choses sont comme ça en
fait on constate que on a des mammifères
du pis quoi
près de 200 millions d'années donc
autant que les dinosaures à ils
survivent aux dinosaures mais à la
limite capé est en fait très peu de
mammifères qui passe la limite cap est
donc eux aussi subissent une extinction
en masse et puis au paléo scène on a des
mammifères qui par rapport à aujourd'hui
sont des mammifères archaïque donc
longtemps on s'est dit ah oui c'est
normal ce sont les descendants de ces
mammifères archaïque du crétacé donc
ceux qui coexistaient avec les
dinosaures
et ensuite les premiers moderne apparaît
c'est aller au sam
ok sauf que quand on regarde en détail
en fait il ya très peu de mammifères qui
passe la limite qu'à pays subissent une
extinction quasi en masse comme les
gobelets dinosaures sauf qu'ils n'ont
pas été complètement anéanti
heureusement pour nous et maintenant on
se rend compte de plus en plus que dans
le palais où scène quand on va voir dans
le détail parce que c'était négliger
longtemps ces mammifères du paléocène ne
sont pas les mêmes que ceux de la fin du
crétacé donc ce qui est rigolo pour des
rigolos curieux on va dire pour des gens
comme moi c'est que longtemps on s'est
penché sur la limite paléocène eocène en
disant qu'elles sont les mammifères
archaïque qui donnent naissance aux
mammifères modernes et maintenant va se
poser la question quels sont les
mammifères archaïque de la fin du
crétacé qui donne les mammifères du
paléocène et voilà on a on a une
évolution en trois étapes
si on veut des mammifères archaïque du
crétacé ensuite d'autres mammifères
archaïque du paléocène et ensuite les
mammifères modernes au début de l'éocène
donc ça devient compliqué c'est d'autant
plus compliqué que se sont ajoutés à ça
il ya quelques années les phylogénie
moléculaire qui qui se sont mis à
balancer des dates
assez assez folle sur l'origine des
mammifères placentaires c'est ça oui oui
oui mais pour les groupes donc dit
moderne on a des datations qui bon je
n'ai pas tellement suivi tout ce qui est
phylogénie moléculaire mais on va un
petit peu dans les deux sens enfin dans
les deux sens
souvent les séparations autres groupes
sont dans du crétacé là où nous
constatons chaque fois qu'on a les plus
anciens représentants à la base de
lausanne
mais force est de constater que ses
premiers représentants ont déjà quand
même toute une série de spécialisation
donc les premières chauves souris ont
déjà des ailes
de type chauve souris les premiers
primates ont déjà les yeux de face les
premiers rongeurs ont déjà les incisives
à croissance continue et moi aussi je
peux continuer comme ça mais il faut
bien qu'ils viennent de quelque chose
c'est pour ça qu'on cherchait tout un
temps dans le palais de st bon de là à
remonter jusqu au crétacé pour dire tout
c'est tous ces ordres vont chercher
naissance dans le crétacé
c'est vrai que pour nous c'est un petit
peu difficile on s'attend pas des dates
aussi reculé par contre ce qu'on a
constaté c'est que dans l'apparition de
certains genres ou de certaines familles
ou les molécules d'ariste nous disait ça
apparaît il ya 10-15 millions d'années
ou pour des genres ou 30 pour des
familles par exemple mais on se retrouve
avec certains genres qui ont plus de 30
millions d'années on a publié il ya pas
longtemps la plus ancienne chauve-souris
appartenant au genre myotis myotis c'est
une chauve souris qui aujourd'hui est
une des plus communes du monde qui se
retrouve presque sur tous les continents
sauf l'antarctique est belle cette
chauve-souris nous on l'a dans nos sites
à 33 millions d'années là où les
molécules ariste l'avait beaucoup plus
jeunes en fait donc là on à l'horloge
des molécules à risque qui se retrouvent
dans l'autre sens tant qu' à mon avis a
des choses à mettre au point
du côté les paléontologues mais aussi du
côté des gens qui font de la phylogénie
moléculaire parce qu'il faut jamais
oublier que la phylogénie moléculaire a
besoin de références et que les
références ce sont des faux cils avec
des datations donc il est comme un
appareillage avec un étalonnage c'est le
l'oeuf et la poule quoi si ça d'accord
donc pour en revenir un petit peu à cet
article et peut-être aux éventuelles
limitations parce que c'est vrai qu'on
fait beaucoup l'éloge de cette étude
mais c'est vrai qu'elle a des limites et
je crois que l'une de ses limites qui
vaut le coup d'être mentionné c'est
qu'on a effectivement une très belle
section mais ça n'est qu'une section est
calé en amérique du nord et que
l'amérique du nord c'est quand même une
faune qui est très atypique au paléo
scène vous voyez tout à fait on a donc
une faune atypique pour nous européens
pour moi européen toi tu es en afrique
du sud qui est atypique pour l'asie
c'est sûr pourquoi parce qu paléocène on
constate que les phones sont très
endémique
donc la faune nord américaine n'est
quasi connu que en amérique du nord avec
quelques groupes qui sont partagés avec
l'asie et quelques groupes qui sont
partagés avec l'europe mais l'essentiel
est typiquement nord américain en europe
c'est la même chose on a nos groupes et
en asie ils ont leur groupe
donc le palier ce n est quand même assez
endémique même si avec les études plus
approfondies des dix vingt dernières
années on a ajouté quelques groupes à la
liste des taxons cosmopolite qui se
baladent sur les trois continents de
l'hémisphère nord
dans l'ensemble on en a très peu allez
hossein c'est juste l'inversé on
constate qu'on a les premiers riffs et
moderne
ils apparaissent extrêmement vite en
quelques dizaines de milliers d'années
il conquérir tout l'hémisphère nord et
on se retrouve avec des groupes qui sont
les mêmes sur les trois continents de
l'hémisphère nord mais aussi des genres
et parfois des espèces qui sont
extrêmement proches voire dans la même
lignée alors qu'on est sur des
continents différents
donc par exemple ce qu'on a dans nos
faune belge on a des taxons qui sont
quasi les en tout cas sur base des dents
et de certains sont exactement les mêmes
qu'au fin fond du wyoming aujourd'hui
après dix mille kilomètres entre la
belgique et le wyoming
mais on a des faunes qui sont quasi les
mêmes sauf que notre action c'est un
petit peu plus petit donc quand même on
a un cosmopolitisme ce qu'on dit au
cosmopolitisme attend une cosmopolitan
isme je crois que cet accord dit
en tout cas on a des fautes qui sont
vraiment les mêmes sur les 3 et mise sur
les trois continents de l'hémisphère
nord alors que au palio scène pas du
tout c'est beaucoup plus endémiques
on a fait ce qu'on a des faunes d'âge
comparable qui sont juste après la
limite cat et en europe et en asie ça
c'est une très bonne question parce
qu'en fait c'est ça qu'il faudrait
chercher en europe le plus en la plus
ancienne phone est justement en belgique
mais elle ne date pas de la base du
palio celles inférieures à celles de la
fin du paléocène inférieur on est à j'ai
envie de dire 62 62 peut-être 63 maximum
millions d'années alors qu'ici il balaye
le premier million d'années donc de 66 à
donc on n'est pas dans le premier
million d'années dans les pyrénées
espagnoles
il ya un taxon qu'ils étaient publiés
qui est un petit multi tubercules et
appartenant à un groupe endémique de
l'europe et je crois qu'il ya cinq six
dons qui ont été publiés mais c'est une
seule bestioles qui était retrouvé dans
une coupe du côté de traîne dans les
pyrénées espagnoles
donc c'est pas toute une faune donc on
sait pas vraiment faire d'études du
timing et de l'évolution des mammifères
à ce moment là donc c'est clair que
c'est la force des américains c'est
d'avoir ce premier million d'années
relativement complet à cet endroit là
avec une faune et qu'ils peuvent étudier
dans le détail
effectivement ils peuvent pas comparé au
reste de la planète donc il faudrait
voir si sur les autres continents on a
la même chose est ce qui se passe dans
le timing dans l'augmentation des masse
corporelle la synchronisation avec ses
réchauffement avec l'apparition de
certains taxons dans les plantes
est-ce que c'est à l'échelle de la
planète
ou est-ce que c'est uniquement en
amérique du nord c'est vrai que c'est la
question suivante qui se posent
mais ça va pas être facile d'y répondre
parce que pour ça il faudrait un
enregistrement fossiles plus complet sur
les autres continents
et est ce qu est ce qu on a une idée de
pourquoi ce pourquoi en amérique du nord
il ya un enregistrement quasi continu
entre le crétacé le paléogène est ce que
est ce qu'on se sait quelles conditions
ont permis ça mais en fait c'est dû aux
montagnes rocheuses le tout ces bassins
sont le londres de la partie est des
rocky mountains et donc comme je disais
depuis l'alberta depuis le canada
jusqu'au nouveau mexique il y en a
partout de ces bassins ce sont des
grands bassins de subsidence certains
qui ont fait une subsidence ac continue
assez complète et on pense souvent
voyais homing parce que c'est ce qui est
le plus cité où on a une énorme
subsidence comme je disais les eaux
sales inférieur qui représente grosso
modo 7 millions d'années et qui a
étalonné sur 1200 mètres
1200 mètres de couches continue quasi
sans hiatus de temps en temps on a est
ce ça correspond à ce qu'ils appellent
des flots de plaine des plaines
d'inondation où on a une alternance de
palais au sol de plaines d'inondation de
palais au sol de plaine inondations et
c'est comme ça pendant des millions
d'années et des faunes qui se retrouvent
en général dans ces paliers au sol et
parfois dans les plaines alluviales on a
des chenaux dont par exemple on a
fouillé des chenaux
en tamisant donc les collègues
américains nous ont appelés pour notre
expertise qu'est le tamisage parce que
dans belgique vu la succession au
riquiqui qu'on a
ben nous on fouillait dans des chenaux
on était content quand il y en avait on
n'a pas une succession 1200 mètres
puisque le reste sont des dépôts marins
en général donc on a l'habitude de
tamiser c'est ce qu'on est allé faire
chez eux dans ses chenaux et donc on a
sorti toute une micro faune qui est
extrêmement concentrée donc il était
assez étonné parce que ils ramassent
donc à même le sol depuis plus d'un
siècle
ils font ils ramassent à même le sol
donc ils ont souvent des très beaux
fossile très complet mais ils n'ont pas
toujours une idée de la variabilité
parce que pour ça il faut retrouver
beaucoup de pouvoir étudier la
variabilité dentaire pour voir un petit
peu tout le commande la souplesse de
chaque taxe on voir sa variabilité
morphologiques et aussi souvent ils
rataient les petites espèces qu'on
retrouve quasi que par tamisage
d'accords mets donc
donc il ya aussi pas mal de choses ça ça
peut être aussi une des des prospectives
perspectives pour le futur de cette
nouvelle étude de cette nouvelle section
ce serait qu'il qu'il regarde un peu
moins les grosses espèces qu'ils ont
trouvé dans ces espèces de nodules là
qu'il nous montre qui est qu'il nous
montre dans les revues de presse et
qu'il s'intéresse plus au tamisage et
éventuellement qu'il trouve aussi plus
importante microfaune une donc une plus
importante diversité oui je pense que ce
serait intéressant d'essayer de trouver
une micro faune ils ont quelques taxes
ou de petite taille mais quand je dis
petit taille le crâne fait quand même
au moins dix centimètres donc pour nous
c'est parfois grand déjà puisque on peut
travailler sur des actions dont le crâne
fait 2 cm donc on voit tout de suite que
la taille des doors ben sera cinq fois
plus réduite aussi et nous retrouve les
dents par tamisage bon faut être honnête
ils ont des craintes complet je
préférais travailler sur des crânes
complexe sur des dents isolées mais
c'est sûr que pour avoir une idée de la
variabilité pour connaître les taxons
qui sont encore plus petit que ses
craintes de 10 cm il faudrait
effectivement probablement fait du
tamisage mais pour ça il faut des
niveaux concentré comme je dis des
niveaux fluviatile donc des remplissages
de rivière il y en a partout
est il que je voulais dire d'autre avec
ça oui ça va augmenter la diversité s'il
trouve ça mais bon voilà il faut savoir
aussi qu pas lieu salle surtout au début
du palio sein la diversité relativement
faible par exemple dans le bassin du san
juan au nouveau mexique
je n'y étaient qu'une seule fois que
quelques jours mais en quelques heures
on trouve des fossiles partout c'est
vraiment impressionnant
mais de nouveaux ramassée au sol donc on
ne sait pas tout on trouve pas toujours
les petites actions et si les chercheurs
ont fouillé la pendant depuis des plus
d'un siècle
en fait ils ont une très faible
diversité
donc on se rend compte que dans les
premiers millions d'années qui suivent
la limite cap et on n'a pas une grande
diversité de mammifères cette très
faible donc pour comprendre pourquoi à
la fin du paléocène on a une telle
diversité et surtout à la base de lait
au sein non à une telle diversité quand
on a les premiers mammifères modernes
d'où vient tous ces mammifères ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est une énigme
[Musique]
oui et puis ce d'autant plus que du coup
il faudrait
il faudrait avoir une meilleure idée de
ce qui se passe ailleurs du coup quand
en amérique du nord puisque comme tu
disais il ya les bassins sédimentaires
en europe et en asie sont très
discontinuer de relative relativement de
petite taille
et puis il ya tout ce qui se passe en
amérique du sud et en afrique où la
basiquement on n'en sait rien oui on
n'en sait rien pour l'afrique ce terrain
a encore dit ah ça c'est certain mais
c'est pas facile des fouilles et non
plus et pour will et en fait on constate
au palais sant qu'on à chaque fois des
faune endémique
mais si les mammifères modernes
apparaissent à la limite paléocène
eocène un peu partout si on voit qu'il
ya quand même des taxes au palio scène
qui sont communs entre continents de
l'hémisphère nord
ça veut quand même dire qu'il ya eu des
échanges il y en a pas eu beaucoup mais
il y en a eu et je pense que parfois il
ne faut pas beaucoup des changes pour
donner naissance à une nouvelle
radiation
il suffit que quelques groupes passent
d'un continent à l'autre
s'ils arrivent à s'y établir il arrive à
résister à la compétition des endémies
qu ils peuvent exploser rapidement et ça
pourrait expliquer pourquoi on a
subitement comme ça dans le bassin nord
américain pareillement des nouveaux
groupes qui apparaissent et qui ensuite
comment se diversifie je vois pas
beaucoup d'autre explication que des
dispersions parce que sinon danser cette
faune les premiers millions d'années de
commandes et de l'amérique du nord
on aurait quand même une plasticité
c'est tellement que je cherchais tous
l'attendent à toronto que je disais
souplesse une plasticité des taxes ou
qui fait ou qui ferait qu elle puisse
donner telle ou telle ligne et or quand
on voit dans le palais scène un petit
peu plus tardif mais c'est que quelques
millions d'années des mammifères
avec des morphologies radicalement
différente de celle du premier million
d'années je vois pas très bien comment
elles peuvent apparaître que par
dispersion par l'immigration d'accord
donc encore pas mal de zones d'ombré du
coup même si donc même si ce nouvel
article nous éclaire sur les quelques
sur le premier million d'années après le
après l'extinction crétacé-tertiaire
finalement ça explique comment ces
groupes archaïque sont apparus mais on
ne sait toujours ça n'explique toujours
pas comment les ancêtres des mammifères
modernes finalement sont apparus sanwi
effectivement ça n'explique pas le
l'apparition des mammifères modernes
mais bon c'était pas vraiment l'objet de
l'article non plus et peut-être
comprendre le premier million d'années
maintenant
ce qui serait intéressant d'en c'est
qu'ils continuent leurs études en
comparant plus en détail avec le
derniers millions d'années et du crétacé
pour voir vraiment ce qui passait ce qui
passe pas parce que là aussi c'est une
grosse énigme
au début on croyait que tous ces
mammifères du paléocène étaient des
descendants des des mammifères du
crétacé on se rend compte que c'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui il ya extrêmement peu
de groupes qui passent donc d'où
viennent ces mammifères du premier
million d'années du paléocène sas et
c'est aussi une énigme
parce que tout un tas de deux groupes
qui sont présentés ici dans cet article
qui est remarquable n'existe pas dans le
derniers millions d'années du crétacé en
amérique du nord dont ces mêmes bassins
donc d'où ils viennent toujours plus de
questions pour ça que j'étudie les bains
fr d'ailleurs il faut gratter les
ménages dehors alors peut-être une
dernière question avant de conclure
quelles sont les possibilités de trouver
de faire une découverte similaire en
europe
ah oui
ben en fait on n'a pas une succession
continue comme dans ce bassin de denver
qui est spectaculaire
ça c'est certain mais on a quand même
des défauts une ancienne comme la faune
de nerfs en belgique qui est le niveau
repères de l'échelle bio chronologique
des mammifères du palio jeunes d'europe
je vais arriver au bout de cette
appellation compliqué et bon
malheureusement ça donne pas des crânes
complet faut pas rêver on a
essentiellement des dents isolées mais
on a les dents isolées de la faune la
plus ancienne du cénozoïque d'europe
donc nous aussi on se demande quelle est
cette faune endémique fin jeudi
endémique parce qu'en fait là je donne
déjà la réponse
elle est endémique parce que justement
elle est pas comme la faune nord
américain on a on a deux ou trois ordre
de mammifères comme un tout le reste
différent
donc on a vraiment des mammifères qui
sont différents en amérique du nord en
europe et en asie on ne connaît pas
leurs origines
sauf pour certains quelques-uns ou
connaît leur origine les autres on ne
sait pas et ensuite ils disparaissent à
des vitesses différentes sur les
continents probablement par des
compétitions sur chaque continent qui
n'ont pas nécessairement les mêmes
il est alors à la limite ou pas les 1
5005 qu'une limite extraordinairement
intéressante je trouve là on a des
échanges on a ces mammifères modernes
qui apparaissent et du coup ces
mammifères archaïque du palais st mais
ils vont disparaître à des vitesses
différentes en fonction des compétitions
locales
ça s'est passé ce qu'on pense c'est ce
qu'on observe et donc pour trouver une
faune remarquable comme celle des
collègues américains
c'est pas gagné en europe parce que on a
sept strati patchwork compliqué il ya
quelquefois assez sympa dans le sud de
la france
mais ce sont des faunes plutôt de
l'éocène inférieur vraiment pour le
paléo scène et le bayeusain anciens et
puis il ya le gisement de wahlbeck en
allemagne qui sont des remplissages
karstique mais qui a donné plus tôt dans
le temps on mettait dans le cas les
sommes supérieures on se rend compte
celi pallesen moyens donc c'est pas mal
mais on a en a on a pas le début de
du palio san je me demande si dans les
pyrénées espagnoles n'aurait pas
fouiller un peu mieux
en tout cas on sait qu'on a on a les
âges à cet endroit là il faudrait
trouver la faune d'accord est tous assez
c'est compliqué tu l'a rapidement évoqué
tous assez compliquée par le fait que à
l'époque l'europe cd il est que chaque
île à son propre niveau aussi
d'endémicité en fait oui oui ça c'est
encore mal connue c'est ce qu'on appelle
le provincialisme alors je me méfie
aussi des grandes théories en disant
voilà c'est du provincialisme il ya le
nord et le sud de l'europe
c'est facile aussi pour expliquer les
différences par contre ça n'explique pas
les similitudes qu'on a on a des texans
qui sont aussi comme un bond à 10 ans
ils ont dû passer donc c'est pas
toujours aussi simples se trouvait
socialisme il faut voir aussi si le fait
d'avoir un ensemble d'îles ne crée pas
aussi tu es comment j'allais dire des
microclimats c'est pas tout à fait ça
mais c'est pas loin
c'est à dire des environnements qui sont
différents à certains endroits qui
peuvent faire qu'on est d'aider faune
qui ont évolué un peu localement et qui
explique des différences donc quand on
est aux alentours de la limite paléocène
eocène par exemple il faut faire très
attention si le taxon auxquels on a
affaire est un taxon appartenant aux
mammifères modernes ou si c'est un taxon
archaïque parce que par exemple on a
dans le début de l'éocène des espèces
modernes des arts cieux d'actifs par
exemple qui dans le nord de l'europe ne
sont pas partir au même genre que ceux
du sud de l'europe mais ne sont pas
serment dans la même lignée on a déjà
des spécialisations alors que ceux du
nord de l'europe vont être dans la même
lignée que ceux qu'on a while you mean
donc il ya vraiment il ya un ballet
géographique est assez compliqué y as
ajoutez à ça l'étude de
la température on a différents maximum
thermique qui se passe durant les au sun
et qui semble expliquer faire on pense
que ça pourrait expliquer une série de
dispersion au gluten
on a une dispersion on n'a peut-être pas
l'origine de mammifères modernes mais on
a les premiers qu'on constate dans dans
les sédiments dans le registre non
fossiles et on constate que c'est ça
coïncide avec un maximum thermique on a
ça apparemment de manière répétée dans
les eaux saines et on voit des petits
changements dans les faunes des taxes
aux qui viennent s'ajouter probablement
par migration à des maximum thermique et
ça ça rejoint l'article de nos collègues
américains
c'est que eux mêmes dans le palio 5 ils
ont une succession où ils sont allés
étudier dans le détail à cent millions
300 mille sept cent mille ans après la
limite k p et il constate pour les trois
événements que je viens de citer trois
réchauffement alors des réchauffements
peut-être pas aussi fort que dans les
hauts seine un sérieux mais trois
réchauffement quand même et donc l'étude
des delà de la paléoclimatologie liés
aux faux ni aux fleurs c'est
probablement quelque chose très
important pour le futur parce
qu'apparemment ces bestioles et ses
plantes elles n'ont pas bougé comme ça
il ya évidemment des raisons d'accord
d'accord et peut-être un petit mot sur
comment ils ont obtenu ces températures
parce qu'il parle d'un échauffement mais
c'est pas enfin généralement les
tempèrent les paléo température on les
mesure avec des isotopes là c'est pas ça
qui l'ont utilisé oui c'est ça donc
d'habitude on étudie on utilise de la
géochimie le carbone 13
ici ils ont utilisé de la paléobotanique
dos qui l'ont étudié des feuilles ils
ont dû déterminer les feuilles les
groupes auxquels des donc des plantes
fossiles à quelle plante fossile ça
appartient et ensuite étudier la forme
de ses feuilles donc les denticules
qu'on a sur les feuilles sur la bordure
des feuilles est indicatrice de la de la
température on peut comparer ça avec la
flore actuel la taille des feuilles joue
aussi là
la novation des feuilles joue aussi et
donc tout ça leur permet de faire des
calculs de température mixant des
calculs par comparaison au flore
actuelle d'accord donc ça demanderait
éventuellement à être appuyé aussi par
des analyses géochimiques dans le futur
oui probablement que si on faisait de la
géochimie ça permettrait mais à mon avis
ça va confirmer ce qu'ils obtiennent
parce que ça pourrait changer l'ordre de
grandeur de des températures mais le
fait qu'ils voient des commandes et des
augmentations de température c'est très
probablement réel quoi ça changera pas
le comment l'information de base
d'accords donc une fois de plus le
réchauffement climatique sera la clé oui
je sais c'est ce qu'on se dit souvent
mais force est de reconnaître que
maintenant quand là la clé on essaye
cette clé dans différentes serrures et
on voit que souvent ça ouvre des portes
bon du coup ça devient un peu à la mode
il faut sans doute pas exagérer mais là
où ça peut être vraiment bien mis en
évidence ça vaut la peine
alors est-ce que tout s'explique par
simplement des réchauffements
climatiques ou des refroidissements
aussi combien de limiter aussi en 2005
je pense que tout s'explique pas par sa
évidemment merci beaucoup
donc là c'est un peu le moment où j'ai
envie de conclure mais peut-être avant
ça est ce que tu veux ce que tu as une
dernière chose quelque chose qui tient à
coeur à dire avant avant la conclusion
on veut rien de particulier si ce n'est
que j'encourage tout le monde à étudier
les mammifères fossiles c'est le
les plus belles études par les
antalgiques qu'on peut faire bien sûr
voilà non je blague mais je suis content
de ton que tu m'aies appelé pour cette
interview sur cette faune vertébrée il
est quand même assez exceptionnel à
nouveau ça tire la couverture vers nos
collègues américains bon c'est publiée
dans la revue américaine science c'est
pas pour rien mais il faut reconnaître
que bon le article en tout cas pour des
spécialistes comme nous l'article est
quand même assez exceptionnel c'est
vraiment une faune exceptionnelle et un
enregistrement exceptionnel donc ça je
ne vais pas je vais pas critiquer nos
collègues
il ya des études de détail à faire c'est
certain mais ça reste quand ils viennent
de faire un grand pas donc là on va voir
la suite avec les yeux bien un écart qui
comme des primates urnes d'accord merci
beaucoup de nous avoir accordé cette
interview
j'espère qu'on se reparlera bientôt pour
de nouvelles découvertes
et puis je vous dis à tous à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne au revoir